let me say it again what I believe
almost everybody here that's selling
direct to consumer or trying to drive
people into store need to do every
company here without knowing a clue of
if people are starting day one or are
very far along is produced somewhere in
the ballpark of 17 to 58 pieces of
organic creative a day against 12 to 25
different consumer segmentations try to
be great at that it's this is not spray
and pray this is not throw against the
wall and see what sticks this is not
test and learn this is Market every day
to your consumers as if it was a print
or radio ad or a commercial every day
thoughtfully put out 50 pieces of
creative watch the algorithms take them
because that's where social is now